[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Hey, everybody.
Hope you're still
enjoying I/O. Today I'm
going to be chatting within
Anil, who's the head of Photos.
And he showed us this
really cool photo stuff
during the keynote.
So Anil, welcome to
"Coffee with a Googler."
ANIL SABHARWA:
Thank you, Laurence.
It's great to be here.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Thanks for coming.
Now one of the things that
you were talking about
was really taking control
of your digital life,
taking control of your photos.
ANIL SABHARWA: Absolutely.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Can you
tell us all about that?
ANIL SABHARWA: Yeah, for sure.
It's really funny.
I often say to
people, it's 2015.
We have cars that
drive themselves.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yes, we do.
ANIL SABHARWA: We've got
drones delivering packages.
But if I want to store or find
my photos, share 20 of them
with you, it's the unsolved
problem of our time.
And so when we talk
about taking back
control of your
digital lives, it's
really about how we're in
this information overload.
And we're with
Photos really trying
to do what Gmail did
for email-- really
make it just easy for you
to be able to not have
to worry about your photos.
Have peace of mind that
they're safely backed up
and you can access
then whenever you want.
Make it really easy to be able
to find that photo so you don't
have to scroll forever,
and be able to make really
great moments, and then
obviously be able to share them
really easily.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sure.
And it gives you this
home for photos, right?
So instead of some photos
being on this device
and I forgot to back these ones
up and I backed those ones up,
it's this one single repository
where I can keep all my photos.
ANIL SABHARWA: Exactly.
And we want to make it such
that you can pick up any device
and you can have access to all
of your photos instantly there.
You don't have to worry about,
oh is that one on my iPhone,
or is that one on
my Android, or is
that one on my home computer?
You just have your entire
life of memories on any device
that you pick up and go
into the Google Photos app.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
Now one of the things
you were showing today
was just how easy it is
to share these photos.
And people don't
need a different app
to get into them or
a permissions link.
How does all that work?
ANIL SABHARWA: So we want
to make sharing really easy.
And I have this with
my wife all the time.
So, you know, she takes a
bunch of photos of the kids.
I take a bunch of
photos of the kids.
And we're trying to exchange
photos because we all
want to hold on to them.
We all want them together.
And normally you have to
share them in some way
or with some app, and then you
download and then you reupload.
And so with Google Photos,
we said, let's just
make it really simple.
So we make it so you can just
select all of the photos really
easily, say Grab a Link.
You can send that
link to anyone.
It's a really secure link.
But anyone who has it can
get access to the photos
and see that content.
And they can just
tap one button,
and all of those
photos and videos
are immediately copied
into their libraries.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
Nice.
Now do they need
to have a Google
ID at least to be able to
sign in to get that storage?
ANIL SABHARWA: If they want to
be able to copy those photos
and videos into their
library, then they
need a Google Photos library,
which means they just
need a standard Google account.
But if they want to just
view the contents-- so
if I want to take the photos
and I want to share them
to, you know, my
kids' grandparents
and I want them to be
able to just access it,
I don't have to worry about it.
I can just send
it over SMS even.
They can click on the link.
And immediately they'll just
see all the beautiful photos
and videos.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's really cool.
And if I'm a Google
Drive user, I
can see all of this in
my Google Drive, right?
ANIL SABHARWA: Exactly.
And that's why we wanted to make
sure between Drive and Photos,
it doesn't matter which
door you come into,
ultimately it's your
photos and videos.
You should have them
accessible in either place.
So photos you put in Drive
can show up in Photos,
and photos that are in Google
Photos are available to you
in Google Drive.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
And I have 15 gigabytes
of storage in Drive,
but I don't need to worry
about all those gigabytes
and pictures because
it's unlimited.
ANIL SABHARWA: Yeah.
Well, so we have essentially
two different ways
that you can store content.
If you care really deeply
about the original bytes--
you want to have the last
bytes down to the very, very
last ones and you
want to make sure
that you can backup raw files
that are 30 megapixels or 4K
video, then we have our
traditional plans where you can
pay $10 a month for a terabyte.
It's still some of the
cheapest storage on the planet.
You get 15 gigabytes for
free across all your Google
services, and that continues.
But as we were talking to people
and we realized the challenges
in this taking back control
of your digital lives,
is we take so many
photos and videos.
And most mobile devices
are less than 16 megapixels
in terms of the
cameras they take.
Almost all the videos people
are producing are 1080p.
And we thought, what if we could
take these photos and videos
that these people
are creating and let
them have peace of mind?
We can back them up
unlimited for free.
And so that's why we
created this ability now
to back up a lifetime of
memories unlimited for free--
under 16 megapixels for
photos, 1080p for HD videos.
And then we use compression
to maintain a near identical
visual quality.
LAURENCE MORONEY: But you showed
that picture of the penguins,
right?
And that was a
compressed picture.
ANIL SABHARWA: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And there was
still just beautiful fidelity
in it, right?
ANIL SABHARWA: Absolutely.
And we have some
examples where we go
and we zoom in at like four
levels of detail and really
in there to the
exact same levels--
and we really try
to make it such
that it's indiscernible
to the human eye,
because our goal-- and
that's why we figure out
the right things based
on the right photos
and we do different techniques,
is because we really
want this to-- you want
comfort that if this
is the only copy of
that photo you have,
we want you to feel incredibly
comfortable and with peace
of mind that you can always
have access to that photo
and it's a good enough
high quality photo.
You can print it.
You can share it.
And it's just like the
memory that you remember
and just like the
photo you took.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
Now my daughter is in
love with penguins.
She absolutely loves penguins.
And when I was looking
at that picture,
I was thinking you were going to
have to send her that picture.
But she's one of these
people-- she's a teenager.
And lots of teenagers, they'll
take out their cell phone
and they'll take picture,
picture, picture, picture,
picture, picture, right?
ANIL SABHARWA: Absolutely.
LAURENCE MORONEY: She'll
take 10 selfies of herself,
and then she'll pick
the right selfie.
And then she doesn't
like the others.
Are we doing anything for
that overwhelming amount
of pictures?
ANIL SABHARWA: Yeah.
I mean, we have just scratched
the surface of all the things
we need to do with Photos.
We're pretty excited about
these three key ideas.
We think there's
more that we can
do to help you easily and safely
back up your life of memories.
We think we want to make
sure it's even easier to be
able to find and organize.
What you're describing is
very much in that category
about, make it easy for me to
hold on to just one of the 10.
And how about when I
share with my wife,
make it really easy for
us to be able to put
those photos in a single place.
There's a lot of really
great opportunities here.
And so we're just getting
started in Photos.
We've got a lot to do.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh.
An I mean, you've done so much.
One thing really piqued
my curiosity this morning.
So you were showing
this thing that
had faces of your relatives.
And you picked your
niece, I believe it was.
And then it showed pictures of
her all the way down to a baby.
But how did it understand that
the baby is the same person,
because the face is
different, right?
ANIL SABHARWA: Yeah.
So we auto-organize your
library by the people, places,
and things that matter.
So in my particular
case, it was very much
my wife, my two kids,
the mother-in-law,
the father-in-law, the
brothers and sisters,
et cetera, friends.
And in the case of the
niece, what we do is we
group faces that are similar
typically within a few years
of an age group.
So for example, in her
case, we would have likely
done something from when she
was baby to being very young
and then something in her
middle toddler age, eight, nine
years old.
And then now when, you know,
she's 10 to 15 years old.
And what we do is we get
high levels of confidence
on those groupings.
But then what we can do is based
on some really great, amazing
computer vision is we can
calculate feature and distance
vectors around how
people naturally age.
And we can start looking
at these three groups
and we can look
at the progression
that someone has had.
And we can say, you know what,
the similarities here-- when
you apply the way
people start to age--
actually make these things look
like they're really, really
close.
And we can bring these three
neighboring clusters together
in a single one and say, hey,
this is actually the same face.
And because we're doing this
100% private for your eyes
only, it's also really easy
for you to go in and say, hey,
you know what Google
Photos, you made a mistake.
These four people,
that's a different baby.
And so we try to do
the best that we can,
but we acknowledge
that every now
and then we're not
going to do it right.
But we make it really easy
for you to tell us and then
still curate those
results in the right way.
LAURENCE MORONEY: We're
running low on time,
but there's one last
question I've got to ask.
And that was the
mountain biking thing,
the videos that you showed.
That was hours of videos, right?
But how was it able to
take those hours of videos
and turn them into that
one exciting moment,
including you taking the tumble?
ANIL SABHARWA: Yeah.
I wish it left that
part out, by the way.
LAURENCE MORONEY: No, I love it.
We're going to to keep it in.
ANIL SABHARWA: So what we do
with our movies is when people
upload lots of videos, we find
that no one really consumes
them, because you typically
get a great three to four
second moment, but you often
capture minutes of video.
In that example, I captured
multiple hours of GoPro footage
when you're mountain biking.
And you upload it
because you're like,
oh, maybe there's
a nugget in here,
but honestly I never
would have got back to it.
And so what Google
Photos did for me is it
analyzed that content.
It looked for what
the best shots
are based on the
composition, the lighting.
It looked for faces.
It looked for motion.
And it gave me particular clips.
And it was able to stitch
that together automatically.
Now it's a starting point.
I can go in and edit it.
I can say, you know what, I
don't want these three clips,
I want to add these, or I
want to change the theme
or soundtrack.
It gives me some options.
But it's a great starting point.
We used some really
great technology
to put that together.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And it just
created a nice little story
for you, right?
ANIL SABHARWA: Exactly.
And that's a moment.
And then I would
share that, right?
I was never going to share four
hours of GoPro footage of me
mountain biking [INAUDIBLE].
LAURENCE MORONEY: [INAUDIBLE]
some people would love
to watch it, but [INAUDIBLE].
ANIL SABHARWA: You're too kind.
I don't think they would.
But, yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
thank you so much, Anil.
That was fabulous.
And the new Google Photos,
it's available to download now
for iOS and Android.
So go check it out.
ANIL SABHARWA: And it's also
on the web-- photos.google.com.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Also on the web.
So I can actually
take my old photos
and upload them on the web?
ANIL SABHARWA: Absolutely.
Right now.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sweet.
photos.google.com.
And it's available
for Android and iOS.
Thank you so much.
ANIL SABHARWA: Thanks, Laurence.
I appreciate the time.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Thank you.
Cheers.